Watson, you beat me again.
Can we just be friends? Yes.
Hello world.
It's Suraj and today we're going to
use IBM's Watson discovery service to
instantly analyze a modern
machine learning paper so
that we can find any issues
encountered by the researchers.
Finding useful patterns and insights
in unstructured data is not easy.
We've continually improve the algorithms
we can use to do so from simple linear
regression models to buy
directional recurrent networks,
but there's still a big problem.
Data preprocessing meaning acquiring,
normalizing,
and organizing unstructured data.
It's something that data scientists
spend as much as 80% of their time on.
If we automate this process,
that frees up much more time to focus on
types of models to use and analyze all
the different results in a
rapid experimentation pipeline.
IBM's Watson Discovery Service is
a great solution to this problem.
It packages core Watson Api APIs like
natural language understanding and
document conversion with simple tooling
that enables us to seamlessly upload and
rich and index large collections
of private or public data.
You don't even need engineering
or machine learning skills.
With the web interface.
Anyone can analyze enormous collections
of unstructured data in minutes.
Discovery uses natural language processing
to allow for analysis for a wide
range of document types,
including html, pdf, and word.
We can also use it to find time based
correlations in data or even identify
locations and geospatial coordinates
to uncover spatial correlations.
It has quite a lot of capabilities that
when combined together offer powerful
insights. For example, if
we're a payments API company,
we can use Watson discovery to identify
all the companies acquired by one of our
competitors over a specific period of
time so we can make more strategic growth
decisions.
If we're a pharmaceutical company,
we can identify the diseases that were
impacted by a target's chemical compound
or if we're working at a shipping company,
we can analyze which events specifically
impact our supply chain or shipping
routes. This kind of data is embedded
in social media, news reports,
legal documents,
and other public or private data as
relationships and text discoveries.
Ability to sift through hundreds of
thousands of relationships to provide
insights is a powerful tool.
The way the pipeline looks is that we
first give discovery our Dataset in
whatever file format it's in.
Then it will convert and enrich that data
using several Watson Api APIs that use
natural language processing to
add metadata to the content,
making it easily searchable as well.
It will also clean and normalize the data.
Once the data is normalized,
it's indexed into a collection as
part of our environment in the cloud.
Then we can query the data to see if
we get any actionable insights from the
output we receive.
So let's try out a demo of this service
for ourselves using a machine learning
paper as our input.
Our first step is to create
a free IBM cloud account.
This is what allows us
to access the service.
Then we'll create an instance of the
discovery service so that we can create an
environment with one or
more data collections that
we will add our content to
and associate with the configuration.
We can click catalog
in the navigation bar.
Then on Watson and the Watson Menu,
we'll find our discovery service and once
there we can click create to wait for
an instance to be created.
After a few seconds,
our new service will be
listed on the dashboard.
We can click on it to open
the discovery service page.
We'll see a complete set
of online tools here,
which we can use to set up an instance
of the service and populate it with data.
We don't need to use API Apis to
configure and populate our service.
We can do it all from the web dashboard.
The content we upload is stored in a
collection that's part of an environment,
but before we upload our content,
we need to create the
environment and collection.
A collection is a logical division of
our data in the environment when we
deliver results,
each collection is query independently.
We'll name our collection machine
learning issues. Once created,
we can upload our documents by uploading
our research paper to our collection.
Once the upload is finished,
we'll see the document count has increased
to one insights from this data will
be listed on the collection page
and we can already see some relevant
information.
Now we're ready to query the data.
We can select our collection from
the discovery tooling main page.
At the top of the collection page,
we'll click on view data schema.
Then we'll click the build queries
link at the top of the data schema page
followed by search for documents.
We want to find out what the issues were
from the paper so we can use natural
language to query for the issues.
We can be as vague or as
specific as we want here.
The more specific we are,
the more targeted the results will be.
When we run the query,
we can click the Jason Table to see
that Jason responses that were returned.
We can see a passage here.
Passages are short excerpts that are
extracted from the full documents that our
query returns.
It seems like the main issue was a very
training time for this type of model,
which confirms my hypothesis.
This is going to make reviewing
papers so much easier.
We can also see some generated semantic
analysis such as sentiment entities,
categories and concepts are
document was converted to Jason,
then enriched and indexed.
By enrichment I mean adding Metadata as
such that Watson functions like entity
extraction,
concept tagging and sentiment analysis
can parse the data accordingly and if we
want we can also access
Watson discovery via the API.
Like in this example it's wrapped via
the python library and we can communicate
with it directly. There are three
things to remember from this video.
IBM's Watson Discovery Service allows
developers to unlock insights hidden in
unstructured data.
We can use it for both public and private
data sets and it uses natural language
processing to help easily extract
semantic elements from data like sentiment
entities and concepts. I've got a
coding challenge for you this week.
Wizards use IBM's discovery service to
build an APP that lets a user analyze the
sentiment around any given
topic that they searched for.
Details are in the get hub link in the
video description and I'll give a shout
out to the top two entries in a week.
Good luck.
Please subscribe for more
programming videos. And for now,
I've got to discover a new API,
so thanks for watching.